bonsoir à tous je suis ravi de vous
retrouver pour cette nouvelle édition du
7 8 sport tout de suite on passe au
sommaire rugby l'armée de l'air
française a rencontré son homologue
britannique pour un match france
angleterre le match était programmé au
stade porchefontaine de versailles tous
les détails dans cette édition football
américain des templiers d'elancourt ont
enregistré ce week-end leur première
victoire de la saison contre les
molosses 12 à 8
nous recevrons sur ce plateau le
receveur des tempes il rappelle tant que
j'ai course à pied la 21e édition de la
nuit aux courses étaient programmées ce
dimanche matin à guyancourt
au total ils étaient 3 111 sportif à
prendre le départ de cette compétition
nous y reviendrons dans ce magazine
et puis en fin d'émission tous les
résultats sportifs du week-end dans le
département la sélection française de
l'armée de l'air de rugby a rencontré
son homologue britannique la royal air
force
la rencontre était programme programmé
mercredi dernier au stade porsche
antenne de versailles les le montage est
signée à exhaler jana un france
angleterre un peu particulier ce
mercredi la sélection française de
l'armée l'air qui joue en noir recevait
lé britannique de la royal air force au
stade porsche l'antenne de versailles
une véritable tradition dans l'armée de
l'air
c'est un match qui avait repris en 1945
et sur la seconde guerre mondiale et
nous avons depuis trois quatre ans à
essayer de remettre ça au goût du jour
afin que nos relations avec nos amis
britanniques soient améliorées et que
l'on améliore par là même le niveau de
rugby au total ils étaient plus d'une
centaine de spectateurs à garnir les
travées du stade de porchefontaine
certains étaient plus célèbre que
d'autres ce sont nos équipes nationales
donc forcément on a tous envie de voir
un crunch même si c'est un crunch armée
de l'air on a toujours toujours envie de
voir une confrontation français
et quand je répète le cadre est très
sympa du monde
ça vaut le coup parce que le jour ne
triche pas sur le terrain et le niveau
et ça me va ce match n'avait d'amical
que le nom les contacts étaient rugueux
et la tension était palpable des deux
côtés après avoir tenu en échec les
anglais pendant plus de soixante-dix
minutes quinze français a craqué à deux
minutes de la fin du match avec deux
essais concédés coup sur coup
score final 20 6 c'était un match serré
et très tactique
c'était très dur de l'ami ce match il
m'a vont réussir à scorer qu'à cinq
minutes de la fin c'était vraiment très
serré concrétiser dans l'âme en forêt et
après par contre toujours moments forts
sont première mi-temps où un deuxième
ils ont marqué ils viennent deux fois en
deuxième mi temps ils marquent deux
essais pareil on prend un matin il sera
au pied droit du sport et du rugby
surtout la sélection française de
l'armée de l'air et les britanniques de
la royal air force devraient se retrouve
en octobre en angleterre pour la coupe
du monde de rugby militaire
les templiers d'elancourt ont repris le
championnat élite de football américain
en février dernier les élans courtois
sûr pour l'instant la sixième place du
classement ils ont remporté ce week-end
leur deuxième victoire contre les
molosses d'asnières 12 à 8
pour nous parler des résultats de
l'équipe nous recevons sur ce plateau
raphaël d'engager le receveur des
templiers
bonsoir bonsoir alors je suppose que
cette victoire fait vraiment beaucoup de
bien en tant qu'il est encore énormément
de bien une victoire méritée
d'abord est nécessaire pour nous pour
éviter la relégation et qui met un écart
entre ces deux équipes en termes de
points donc voilà dans beaucoup de bien
et qu'est ce qui a fonctionné du coup
sur ce match petit qui a fonctionné
c'est notre défense très grosse défense
qui a fait un gros travail pendant toute
la partie
hormis ce qu'on peut considérer comme
une faute d'inattention début de match
mais sinon elle a été irréprochable sur
tout le reste du match
et est ce que vous allez retrouver
peut-être certaines valeurs qui vous
faisait défaut depuis le début de la
saison
vous avez enchaîné pas mal de résultats
négatifs notamment la maison est ce que
vous allez retrouver ces valeurs là bas
on sait qu'on peut compter sur nos
capacités athlétiques physique qu'on ne
lâche rien on a confiance en nous on
sait que à tout moment on peut faire la
différence est vrai jusqu'au bout on se
voit et c'est ce qui s'est passé le
samedi
et justement c'est très compliqué c'est
match élite vous les sentez vraiment
enfin le niveau des équipes est vraiment
rapproché c'est ça peut-être qu'il fait
là et qui fait la différence cette année
cette année oui exactement c'est vrai
dans l'envoi des résultats auxquels
s'attendaient pas on se rend compte que
n'importe quelle équipe peut gagner
cette année donc c'est assez serré entre
chaque équipe et donc vous avez remporté
ce match dans la douleur quand même 12 à
justement est-ce que ça peut permettre
de souder ce groupe
oui je pense et comme je disais on a vu
que à tout le monde pouvait faire la
différence et c'est bien de le savoir et
c'est notre deuxième victoire d'affilée
donc on espère que ça va continuer on va
tout faire pour vous avez emporté pour
l'instant deux matches depuis le début
de la saison est-ce que c'est
préoccupant préoccupant serait pu l'être
si on avait perdu samedi maintenant ça
va un peu mieux et comme je disais on va
tout faire pour
pour que ça continue comme ça et comment
expliquez vous justement les résultats
des templiers d'elancourt vous visitiez
parmi les favoris en début de saison
qu'est-ce qui a justement manqué aux
templiers d'elancourt sur 7 ses premiers
matches sur ses six premiers matches on
va dire alors c'est vrai qu'on a
l'habitude de voir les templiers plus
haut dans le classement
notamment avec l'année dernière quand
vous avez fait quand même une maison
quand même exactement par câble mais ce
qu'il ya c'est qu'on a eu un effectif
plus réduit cette année donc il nous a
fallu un temps d'adaptation
donc voila mais donc début compliqué
maintenant ça va mieux on a réussi à
rattraper tout ça et s'améliorer et les
apports des deux un porc américain je
pense a donc aux dérèglements des axes
show est ce qu'ils se sont bien
acclimatés au jeu français où est-ce
qu'ils ont encore besoin de s'acclimater
c'est peut-être ça peut-être qui
explique aussi les les défaillances du
jeu des templiers belattar en ce début
de saison je pense pas que ce soit lié
uniquement à ça surtout que notre cul
bea a une première expérience en europe
dont connais un peu la façon de jouer
qu'on a on ne repart pas aux états unis
et ce qui concerne donc l'autre anelka
en défense il a pas il ya pas de soucis
et tous les biens produits et donc donc
c'est peut-être qu'il pourra apporter
peut-être un petit peu plus quand même
offert à mesure de la saison pour
l'instant au niveau de leurs stats c'est
ce qu'ils apportent suffisamment à
l'équipe
genre je connais pas exactement les
stats mais je pense que ça doit être ça
corresponde à ce qu'on attendait d'eux
chance et au niveau du leadership
il apporte quelque chose peut-être ça
fait toujours une différence d'avoir des
américains dans une équipe par rapport à
la différence par rapport à ça la
différence culturelle qu'il ya c'est
quand même leur sport à la base donc
donc ça fait du bien de les avoir avec
nous le président georges agostino été
mis sur ce plateau il ya deux mois juste
avant le début de la saison il nous
parlait de coupe d'europe
est ce qu'on peut dire que cet objectif
ne sera jamais à temps on peut pas
savoir je préfère pas parler de coupe
d'europe maintenant jugnauth début de
saison je pense que pour nous le plus
important c'est de continuer à bien
jouer s'améliorer et c'est d'avoir le
plus de victoires possibles et on verra
à la fin où ça nous mène est-ce que vous
pensez que c'est réalisable quand même
cet objectif de coupe d'europe tout est
possible après je pense que au niveau
mathématique ça dépend pas forcément que
de nous en tout cas on françois de ganay
tous nos prochains matches donc on verra
à ce moment-là mais qu'est ce qu'il
faudra faire justement pour pour
atteindre 7,7 coupe d'europe c'est
vraiment faire un sans-faute maintenant
sans faute
continuer à se battre et jusqu'au bout
jusqu'à la fin des matches comme on l'a
fait samedi et l'équipe en a les moyens
bien sûr bien sûr toujours et quels sont
les principaux concurrents des templiers
du coup pour cette fin de saison
on voit que les cougars de
saint-ouen-l'aumône sont premiers du
classement actuellement est ce que ce
sont vraiment les favoris de ce
championnat
ils sont invaincus
ils prétendent au titre évidemment donc
ce sera un gros concurrent
est-ce que c'est mérité qu'ils soient
premiers pour l'instant vu leurs matches
on peut dire que c'est mérité
et est ce que ce sera l'équipe justement
qu'il faudra aller chercher cette équipe
là où il y aura peut-être d'autres
équipes y en aura il y en a trois ou
quatre au qu'il faudra peut-être en
c'est pas encore ça dépend ça va
dépendre des autres matchs jeu ça dépend
pas que de nous mais mais c'est sûr que
ce qu'on veut c'est gagner tous nos
matches et surtout tous nos matches à
domicile surtout merci raphaëla
d'engager dès la prestation c au plateau
où serait de terminer cette saison donc
en boulet de canon pour accrocher cette
cette place en coupe d'europe on passe
maintenant à la course à pied la 21e
édition de la glu aux courses étaient
programmées ce dimanche à doha commune
de guyancourt
au total ils étaient 3 111 sportif à
prendre le départ de cette compétition
les images sont signés elodie moelle une
grande boucle dans la nature un parcours
vallonné de longues lignes droites sur
la route bienvenue sur la nuit en course
ce dimanche pour cette 21e édition 300
ce courageux ont pris le départ des 10
km les sportifs ont une nouvelle fois
souffert pour atteindre la ligne
d'arrivée
il ya quelques difficultés notamment au
cette septième kilomètre à peu près il
ya une petite côte à monter qui sera
précédé de quelques escaliers aussi donc
je pense que les coureurs à ce niveau là
quand on commencera à avoir mal aux
jambes c'était une course difficile
cette fois ci parce qu'ils ont eu la
très bonne idée de nous mettre des
escaliers au milieu du parcours
juste avant une petite côte donc c'était
le double effet kiss cool avec un grand
soleil printanier des température plutôt
douce le temps était idéal ce dimanche
pour réaliser des performances
pascal bredele à saint quentin en
yvelines a terminé sur la plus haute
marche du podium
il a fini la course en 34 minutes 0-2 le
coureur devant son dauphin françois
l'acquis de près d'une minute et
conditions climatiques a été vraiment
excellente et il le soleil était
n'accuse à ses frais ce qui permettait
de bien respirer durant sa course
donc voila c'était franchement un très
très grand plaisir
d'autant plus qu'on a eu beaucoup de
participants étaient 350 le week-end de
pâques non franchement c'est un réel
plaisir pour les coureurs mais aussi
pour les organisateurs
rendez vous l'année prochaine pour une
22e édition de la revue en course les
coureurs sont déjà impatients
vivement l'année prochaine il vivement
la prochaine grille en course
en basket le fc trappes saint quentin en
yvelines a enchaîné une série de sept
victoires consécutives en nationale 3
une série qui s'est stoppée ce week-end
les hommes de mustapha el hafidi ont
perdu sur le terrain de bois ni 79 à 66
pour nous parler des performances de
trappes sur cette phase retour nous
recevons sur ce plateau le président
jacques michelet bonsoir pour soi et le
pivot jowhé casseus bonsoir alors
justement jacques michel et comment on
explique cette bonne dynamique du tout
club des trappes de sur cette phase
retour juste en mai nous avons récupéré
en fait l'ensemble de notre nos éléments
en ce début d'année ce qui déjà nous a
permis d'avoir un autre niveau de
performance que ce qu'au match aller où
nous a manqué d'une manière systématique
de voir trois éléments majeurs de
l'équipe
ça c'est une première chose le deuxième
chose c'est que nous avions combler ces
manques au match aller par l'arrivée de
réservistes et qui ont dû se mettre dans
le bain et qui je crois on commençait à
devenir opérateur opérationnel durant
ces matchs retour et puis et puis il ya
un troisième élément si vous permettez
il ya un troisième élément c'est que en
fait ce groupe s'est constitué de cette
manière et je crois que avec ces matches
retour il est arrivé à peu près à
maturité est ce qu'il ya eu un déclic
sur sur le mois de janvier on voit que
la série commence au mois de janvier
est-ce qu'ils aient eu un déclic je sais
pas peut-être des hommes qui ont pris la
parole dans le vestiaire pour vraiment
apporter une nouvelle dynamique à
trappes
je ne sais pas si on peut parler de
déclic parce qu'en fait on a eu ce
travail de construction du groupe durant
l'ensemble des matches aller mais ça ça
te prête pas ça se construit
nous avions nous avons vu en fait le
nôtre basket progressé durant tous ces
matches aller malgré les défaites et au
match retour
en fait ça s'est concrétisé
peut-être par une harmonie dans le
groupe tout entier il y a eu
effectivement des débats mais dire que
c'est seulement à un moment donné au
début de l'année qu'il ya eu débat non
je crois qu'il y a eu des échanges dans
les vestiaires entre les joueurs entre
les joueurs les dirigeants de façon à
mieux comprendre et bien et surtout à
faire en sorte que chacun puisse donner
le maximum de lui-même
et qu'est ce qui a fait qu'est ce qui
fait la force de ce groupe maintenant eh
bien je crois que c'est justement ce
l'homogénéité la bonne compréhension la
de chaque membre de l'équipe à l'égard
de chacun des autres il y à ce que
j'appellerais effectivement un esprit de
groupe où on ne culpabilise pas parce
qu'on a raté quelque chose où cette
scénariste cette solidarité s'exprime
bien sûr sur le parquet mais également
autour nous sommes de ce point de vue la
dent en reconstruction par rapport à
l'année précédente
donc il était normal également qu'elle
nous rencontrions quelques difficultés
en ce début de deuxième saison
d'autant plus que c'est tombé très mal
puisque nous avons eu immédiatement
plusieurs blessés parmi des éléments
majeurs
j'aurais casseus vous allez intégrer du
coup l'équipe vous étiez blessé cette
saison vous avez intégré l'équipe
l'année prochaine
ce groupe vous l'avez peut-être vu à
l'oeuvre pour l'instant en fait moi je
suis
j'étais blessé actuellement j'ai suivi
le groupe de saint quentin en yvelines
via les réseaux
surtout sur internet avec les vidéos et
je vois qu'ils sont venus que c'est un
dynamique
donc on va faire nous l'année prochaine
c'est qu'on va rester justement sur ce
cette dynamique là et aider le club à se
reconstruire de nouveaux âges les
premiers rôles en championnat il ya
vraiment un bon état d'esprit
chaque michelin seulement ce groupe je
crois que ça s'améliore tous les jours
et puis d'ailleurs je crois également
que l'intégration de nouveaux ennemis
comme jouer ici présents et bien se font
sous les meilleurs auspices s est-ce
qu'il ya peut-être un regret sur cette
saison quand on voit que que finalement
la saison 2 de trappes a réellement
commencé au mois de janvier est ce qu'il
ya un petit regret quand même de se dire
qu'on vous auriez pu viser plus haut
vous serez sûrement 5e à la fin de la
saison
vous aurez peut-être plus viser la
montée cette année on peut toujours se
le dire cependant je crois que cette
année a été une année de reconstruction
si sur le plan sportif on peut le
regretter certes mais les résultats des
matches retour sont le produit des
efforts réalisés sur le match aller donc
dire que la valeur de l'équipe
mériterait mieux certainement
cependant eu un championnat ça se passe
pas seulement sur les matches retour il
est donc je pense que nous sommes
relativement à notre place aujourd'hui
ça c'est premièrement deuxième élément
c'est qu'en fait une équipe en
reconstruction ça se confirme il n'y a
pas seulement le plan sportif mais il ya
aussi le plan économique social et c'est
qu'il s'agit de mettre en cohérence
totale avec le plan sportif
et de ce point de vue là je croyais je
crois que cette année à a été une année
de transition
de façon à ce que nous repartions comme
disait jo est tout de suite sur
d'excellentes bases à la fois sur le
plan sportif est à la fois sur le plan
économique pour l'année prochaine et
justement c'est cette bonne dynamique
que vous avez depuis quelques mois
est ce que vous allez vous en servir
pour construire votre groupe pour
l'année prochaine
bien sûr c'est tout à fait évident c'est
cette année il y aura de toute manière
c'est vrai toujours des quelques
éléments qui vont partir qui d'autres
qui vont arriver
le groupe n'est pas encore constitué
vraiment il y a il y aura quand même un
noyau dur peut-être il ya un noyau 2 qui
va rester il ya un noyau dur qui va
rester ce qui nous fait dire que
justement on peut on pourra bénéficier
de cette dynamique
et puis je crois que les éléments parmi
les éléments qui vont intégrer et ont
joué en fait de fait il y en ait un
autre un autre également que vous avez
vus à d'autres dernière émission
moustafa qui est américain et qui lui
aussi a vu le club et lui a fait partie
déjà 2 de l'activité sportif du club
cette année ce qui fait qu' il n'y aura
pas ce temps d'adaptation que nous avons
dû avoir en début de cette année vous
allez prendre la taille aussi l'année
prochaine et nous avons pu vérifier si
vous faites les deux mètres de vous un
sessad m doussain et du coup c'est
l'objectif c'est vraiment de excusez la
porte l équipe vous c'est vraiment votre
impact sur les rebonds ouais mon impact
sur les eurobonds ma défense après je
pense que pas mon humilité mon travail
comme j'ai dit c'est apporter une valeur
ajoutée à cette équipe qui a déjà fait
une belle deuxième partie de saison
donc moi j'intègre le groupe et avec mon
énergie et c'est de cette fois ci faire
une saison complète et viser la première
place sur tout et quel est votre votre
point fort à mon point fort comme
voulais dire c'est 2 rebonds en premier
lieu et mon énergie mon envie de me
battre et vous êtes vous avez joué ou
dans le passé je jouais notamment
antibes
en pro b je jouais à angers à saint
brieuc je vais beaucoup de clubs en
france donc on t'a apporté mais
également votre votre expérience
d'expérience comme et vous avez quel âge
j'ai 26 ans d'accord et donc donc
l'objectif ça sera peut-être de
d'apporter justement votre expérience et
de justement faire passer un palier à
l'équipe des trappes
c'est ça comme je dis tout en humilité
en travaillant et 1 et en travaillant
tous les jours à l'entraînement avec mes
futurs coéquipiers avec une nouvelle
dynamique au club on va essayer de de
faire quelque chose de bien je pense et
vous avez le coach au téléphone
mustapha el hafi liban encore encore ga
des échos de lui lui aussi a des échos
de moi on va se voir très prochainement
et je sais que c'est un coach qui est
très pointilleux notamment tactiquement
c'est vraiment un passé de basket et on
va faire une bonne collaboration qui
donne beaucoup d'importance à la défense
a également exactement et je crois que
jouer et robots d'astier une autre
qualité qui nous a qui nous a fait le
recruter ce sont ces qualités humaines
il a parlé de plusieurs fois de
d'humilité et moi je dirais que c'est
ses qualités de communication dans le
groupe d'animation de groupe sont sont
parmi des qualités tout à fait essentiel
à notre avis nous plaçons ces qualités
là au dessus même des qualités physiques
qu'on peut rencontrer chez tel ou tel
joueur
et justement il est très loin d'en être
dépourvu de ses qualités et la saison
prochaine va se faire avec ou sans moi
staff à l'infini vous allez bien
décision fenêtre - n'avons pas pris de
décision pour l'instant il n'y a je n'ai
pas d'éléments à vous donner c'est que
sais tu ce sont des décisions qui se
prennent avec de manager général bien
sûr donc qui n'est pas là pour l'instant
puisqu'il a en déplacement professionnel
pendant trois semaines la jeune on
pourra vous en dire plus dans quelques
semaines fin du mois sans doute est donc
l'objectif clairement annoncé cesser la
montée la saison prochaine tout à fait
je viens de le dire l'instant mais le
président l'a dit également la montée
fois c'est en prochaine oui je le dis
oui effectivement
si tout se passe bien encore une fois et
je dirais aussi que comme durée en toute
humilité également nous savons trop bien
combien les aléas peuvent contrecarrer
les meilleures espérances
merci jacques nichet merci du et ak
steel est bâti sur ce plateau
bon courage pour votre dernier match
contre le mans donc c'est ce samedi
un petit pronostic et bien écoutez nous
espérons que le dernier mad le match
dernier plutôt n'a été qu'une erreur et
que nous allons faire nous allons
renouer avec la victoire on l'espère je
dirais que c'est le propre de tout
sportif d'essayer de gagner
nous avons affaire à une équipe très
bien classé bien sûr de grandes qualités
sont son tassement n'est pas hasard du
tout on essaiera de montrer que
le dernier match est une vie qu'un faux
pas en espérant que nos pronostics se
révélera sur le terrain merci beaucoup
jacques michel et on passe maintenant
aux autres résultats du week end les
championnats départementaux de pony
games était organisée ce week-end au
centre équestre de l'île de loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines
une vingtaine d'équipés yvelinoise
composé de cinq cavaliers ont participé
à la compétition marc ojani marion
jeanniot du club hippique ville vers
deux jours josas nous présente cette
discipline a été au micro d' elodie
moines le pony games et surtout des jeux
de rapidité d'agilité de patience
parfois des équipes parce que l'esprit
d'équipé très important et voilà il ya
des jeux avec des bals des conapo enfin
des balles à poser sur les cônes des
cartons à mettre dans des seaux enfin
c'est très divers ça bouge ça envoie on
n'est pas fan change de dusseau dresse
basique à l'esprit d'équipé que je
trouve ça génial et vendre du côté les
résultats c'est le club hippique ville
vers 2 juin josas qui a emporté à la
compétition en base en baseball les
cougars de montillot bretons ont
organisé ce week-end leur 19e tournoi de
pâques une compétition amicale avec
quatre équipes une bonne session
d'entraînement pour les signé mon teint
qui débutent leur saison ce dimanche
avec un déplacement à la rochelle en
deuxième division
on écoute mathieu dufour joueurs des
cougars c'est un bon échauffement on
s'entraîne beaucoup
pendant l'hiver en attendant patiemment
les matches pendant la saison donc là
c'est juste avant la saison c'est
parfait pour penser chauffer on voit on
voit les jeunes qui font qu'ils font du
bon boulot c'est bien c'est bien pour
tout le monde c'est un tournoi qui est
d'après pas même si la saison a commencé
pour la régionale 2 et la régionale 1
mais c'est quand même aussi un tournoi
qui aide à entrer dans la saison de
baseball lors de ce tournoi de pâques ce
sont les sens de saint germain en laye
qui se sont illustrés l'équipe a
remporté le tournoi devant un
montigny-le-bretonneux
en foot ball trap a remporté une
précieuse victoire sur le terrain de jeu
de vie et ce dimanche lors de la 18e
journée de championnat de promotion
d'honneur
score final 2 buts à 0 pour les
trappistes au classement trappe réalise
la bonne opération de cette journée le
club se hisse à la huitième place du
championnat ils devraient se maintenir
dans cette division l'année prochaine
parisi reste leader du classement avec
50 points devant chatou on passe au
football féminin et l'encours a réalisé
la bonne opération de ce week-end en
remportant son match en retard contre
argenteuil les élans courtois se sont
imposés 3 buts à 1 à l'extérieur au
classement et l'encours s'offrent une
bouffée d'oxygène les ivy noah sort de
la zone rouge et compte désormais trois
points d'avancé sur ffa à 77 le rallye
des gazelles s'est achevée ce week end
au maroc les trappistes laurence
bataille séverine sous laon terminé à la
64e place du classement sur 88 dans la
catégorie 4 4 première participation la
plaisir oise laura boog and a fait
légèrement mieux avec sa coéquipière kit
williams le duo a fini la course à la
62e place cette catégorie a été dominé
par les américaines nicolas pitel et
jesse comme on passe à l'agenda du
week-end
en basket trappeur reçoit le mans pour
le dernier match du championnat de
nationale 3 les hommes de mustapha el
hafidi n'ont plus grand chose à espérer
au classement il devrait terminer à une
belle cinquième place après un début de
saison très compliqué si vous voulez les
encourager pour leur dernière sortie le
match est programmé ce samedi à 20
heures au gymnase paul mallet et puis
handball le ch est né reçoit beauvais ce
dimanche à 16 heures au gymnase nouvelle
france pour le compte de la 19e journée
de national troyes l'échiné siens
doivent l'emporter pour rebondir après
leur défaite contre les leaders lille
une victoire pourrait leur permettre de
recoller au premier c'est la fin de
cette fuite sport merci d'avoir suivi je
vous retrouve lundi prochain pour un
nouveau magazine
très bonne soirée sur tv fil 78